there are over 20 000 different  cryptocurrencies and some of them are  scams some of them are terribly  centralized some of them are vc backed  some of them are meme coins there's only  a few which will truly survive and in my  opinion it's gonna be bitcoin why  because of what bitcoin is it's the only  truly decentralized cryptocurrency it's  never been hacked and the rules of the  network are set in stone so the same way  the monetary policy in the uk the us  whatever it is the central bank has the  ability to change monetary policy they  can print more money right with bitcoin  there's only ever going to be 21 million  you cannot create more so you have those  laws set in stone ethereum is kind of  wobbly because the mechanism which uh  secures the network is changing so now  it's like also your laws aren't set in  stone